la primera carga de cereales ucranianos
llegó a su lugar de destino tres días de
haber zarpado el transportador de granos
por la Net arribó al norte de Turquía
con 12.000 toneladas de maíz
convirtiéndose en la primera entrega
efectiva desde que el mes pasado se
firmó el acuerdo que busca desbloquear
las más de 20 millones de toneladas de
cereales que se acumularon en los
puertos de Ucrania desde la invasión
rusa este lunes también zarparon otros
dos barcos desde puertos de la región de
odesa con destino a Italia y Turquía con
11.000 toneladas de soja y más de 48.000
toneladas de maíz en una ruta por el mar
Negro que el capitán de uno de los
barcos ha calificado como desafiante y
peligrosa
hubo 17 tramos hasta la llegada a
Estambul de corto medio y largo alcance
estas eran por supuesto áreas peligrosas
corredores que habían sido despejados
desminados dejamos zonas de riesgo a
medida que nos acercábamos a las aguas
territoriales rumanas
en un revés para toda la operación de
entrega de alimentos este lunes el
comprador libanés rechazó el cargamento
del barco razoni que salió desde Ucrania
el primero de agosto debido al retraso
en la entrega de la mercancía según la
embajada ucraniana en beirut El vendedor
ahora Busca un nuevo interesado en la
compra de grano dentro o fuera del
Líbano mientras que la administración
militar de Odessa dio a conocer el
inicio del funcionamiento del Tercer
gran puerto de la región
Elgin lo que Ucrania está haciendo hoy
es salvar al mundo del hambre entonces
vemos como hoy el enemigo la federación
rusa cumple Los acuerdos alcanzados con
Turquía y la ONU es decir con la
organización en los países garantes
la guerra provocó una crisis alimentaria
que afectó sobre todo a países de
oriente medio y África en tiempos de paz
Ucrania exportaba hasta 6 millones de
toneladas de cereales al mes en las
costas del mar Negro y el mar de